Trascrizione: Nicole Gadler
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Io vi parlo dei talenti
che devono ancora emergere,
nel senso che tutti noi uomini di azienda
abbiamo l’abitudine di parlare dei talenti
che devono entrare nelle aziende,
che dobbiamo attrarre,
che dobbiamo trattenere,
che dobbiamo allevare,
con cui dobbiamo condividere
il futuro delle nostre imprese.
Io voglio parlarvi dei talenti che sono
ancora fuori dall’azienda,
che non sono emersi,
ma che sappiamo che ci sono.
Noi abbiamo un grande problema.
Abbiamo il problema
di questi 3 milioni di talenti
che sono fuori dal mondo del lavoro,
che sono i NEET o “NIIT”,
se vogliamo pronunciarlo meglio,
che è una sigla ormai nota a molti.
Che vuol dire, che sono 3 milioni
di giovani che non lavorano, non studiano,
non sono in formazione, non fanno niente.
Sono giovani dai 15 ai 34 anni,
adottiamo le statistiche
prodotte dal Ministero del lavoro.
E un quarto dei giovani che sono in questo
raggio d’età appartengono appunto i NEET.
Esattamente il 23%,
un numero enorme,
una situazione davvero disastrosa.
È un fenomeno italiano.
È un fenomeno europeo, ma è un fenomeno
particolarmente italiano,
che si registra qui da noi,
dove c’è il numero più grande in Europa.
La media europea dei NEET
è intorno al 13%.
L’Olanda è il Paese più ritroso, il 5%.
L’Italia, insieme alla Romania, è il Paese
che sta in fondo alla classifica
con il 23% di giovani che non studiano,
non lavorano e non fanno formazione.
Il tasso di occupazione in Italia
è del 60%.
Era del 59, leggermente aumentato
negli ultimi mesi.
Il tasso medio europeo è del 70%.
Ma andiamo un po’ più in profondità
su questi dati per conoscerli meglio.
Dei 3 milioni disoccupati sappiamo,
ce lo dice il Ministero del Lavoro
in base alle indagini che conduce
sul territorio attraverso le Regioni
e i centri per l’impiego, un milione
di questi giovani sta cercando un lavoro.
E qui potremmo chiederci perché
sta cercando un lavoro, ma non lo trova
quando tutti sappiamo
che abbiamo bisogno di lavoratori.
Ma il dato certo è che 2 milioni
di questi giovani non cercano un lavoro,
cioè non hanno nessun interesse
a ritornare al lavoro,
perché hanno trovato una loro stabilità
nel non avere impegni
all’interno di una comunità.
Allora come è stato possibile,
mi domando e vi domando,
e ve lo consegno alla vostra riflessione,
una situazione di questo genere
in cui siamo il fanalino di coda in Europa
sull’occupazione giovanile
dai 15 ai 34 anni?
Come è stato possibile?
Dove sono le responsabilità?
E dobbiamo dircelo.
Sono nei genitori,
che molto spesso hanno tollerato
che i figli potessero stare a casa
senza far nulla
e che quasi in qualche modo per registrare
il loro successo di reddito
hanno detto: “Stai a casa, che un piatto
di minestra per te ci sarà sempre”,
condannando in questo modo il figlio
a un’inattività veramente pericolosa.
Le responsabilità stanno
nel mondo della scuola,
dove c’è un abbandono scolastico,
anche qua,
con numeri che sono tra i primi
in Europa, e non sempre, anzi quasi mai,
la scuola tenta di andare ad un recupero
di questi studenti che lasciano la scuola
e che non vengono ormai
nemmeno più censiti.
C’è un sistema pubblico inefficiente,
un sistema pubblico inefficiente
che non è in grado, con Informagiovani
dei Comuni o con i centri per l’impiego,
di dare delle risposte non burocratiche
a chi per caso
si affaccia nei loro uffici.
E c’è in generale una cultura nostra,
di tutto il nostro Paese,
che non condanna
a sufficienza l’inattività.
E anzi,
che in qualche caso li incoraggia,
o non la vede
come un fenomeno così negativo.
Bene, dobbiamo lavorare tutti insieme
per rovesciare queste impostazioni.
Perché un giovane deve entrare subito
nel mondo del lavoro
quando finisce la scuola.
Nei primi anni
della Youth Guarantee europea,
dove pochi giovani allora trovarono
un lavoro con la Youth Guarantee,
ma le statistiche ci hanno spiegato dopo
che il 70% di loro ha trovato lavoro
da solo, perché era passato attraverso...
in un’azienda.
E quindi rafforziamo questi strumenti,
puniamo gli abusi,
ma utilizziamo al massimo
per ottenere questi risultati.
Poi dobbiamo rafforzare
la prevenzione pubblica,
quindi tutto ciò che il pubblico può fare.
Dobbiamo copiare
le buone pratiche in Europa
che sono facilmente assimilabili,
ma dove deve esserci la volontà politica,
la volontà sindacale,
la volontà dei genitori di prendere
queste pratiche e di portarle in Italia.
Dal Belgio, dall’Olanda,
dalla Francia, dalla Germania.
C’è solo l’imbarazzo della scelta.
Auto-imprenditorialità significa
che io ti devo aiutare,
non solo per fare la start up tecnologica,
che ovviamente è importantissima e su cui
ci sono copiosissimi finanziamenti,
ma ti posso anche aiutare a fare
la start up più semplice,
quella artigianale,
dove si può creare lavoro
per nuclei di due, tre, quattro giovani
e di cui la società ha bisogno.
E quindi come rintracciamo queste persone?
Le rintracciamo attraverso le famiglie,
convincendo i genitori, i loro amici,
che così non possono andare avanti.
Bisogna che si muovano gli insegnanti,
per andare ai recuperi
di cui abbiamo parlato,
che sono fondamentali
perché abbiamo ancora un tasso scolastico,
come sapete, rispetto all’Europa,
molto basso.
E poi, una volta trovati
i NEET che cosa facciamo?
Anche qui abbiamo
una straordinaria novità.
Il GOL, la Garanzia Occupabilità
dei Lavoratori,
un grande finanziamento europeo
di 5 miliardi
da spendere nei prossimi tre anni.
Mezzo miliardo è già stato impiegato
per le assunzioni
e il rafforzamento dei centri
per l’impiego.
Ma rimangono 4 miliardi e mezzo,
che è una cifra che non è
mai stata utilizzata in Italia
sulle politiche attive.
Quindi sono uno strumento formidabile,
sia per fare tutta l’attività preparatoria
di profilazione e di accompagnamento,
ma sia, soprattutto, per fare formazione,
per dare delle risposte precise
a dei desideri legittimi
di una parte di questi lavoratori.
Quindi abbiamo questa grande opportunità
per i prossimi tre anni,
ma la sapremo utilizzare se ci sarà
un impegno di tutta la società
su questo fronte.
Perché i talenti ci sono anche
in questi 3 milioni di ragazzi
che sono ancora fuori.
È un obiettivo strategico per l’Italia.
Deve diventare un obiettivo strategico
per l’Italia, per tutti.
Purtroppo non basta una legge,
magari bastasse una legge,
un decreto legge, un disegno di legge,
qualsiasi cosa.
No, ci vuole convinzione,
ci vuole una grande forza e ci vuole
una grande generosità da parte di tutti.
Grazie.